okay so the topic of today's video will
be evolution by natural selection so
let's go ahead and get started well
before getting into natural selection I
want to mention artificial selection and
that's basically selective breeding of
dogs and crops and livestock and we've
been doing it for centuries great
example are wolves through selective
breeding we've bred all kinds of variety
of domesticated dogs by controlling the
breeding of for instance wolves we've
been able to cause change in dogs well
we see this in plants as well you know
in crops you know through selective
breeding of wild mustard we've actually
produced you know brussel sprouts and
cabbage and kale and all the vegetables
you probably hated as a kid but through
selective breeding of wild mustard have
been able to produce these various types
of food products you know we've been
able to produce bigger and Meteor
livestock cows chickens pigs over the
centuries by controlling which ones were
able to reproduce with one another so
we've actually caused change humans have
actually caused changed too many
organisms on this planet so an
artificial selection humans are the
driving force we are the ones that are
selecting the desirable trait that we
want to enhance when we allow one
organism to breed with another organism
and so the whole point of artificial
selection is that it proves that by
controlling the breeding of how
organisms reproduce with one another
that over time this can make the change
now the question is can this process of
change happen naturally without human
interference science believes the answer
is yes and that would be natural
selection
so that brings us to natural selection
the process through which organisms with
advantageous traits are more likely to
survive and reproduce
you know this theory was proposed by
Charles Darwin and you might know that
on board the HMS Beagle he set forth on
a five-year journey that wrapped around
you know South America and explored
various parts of the world and they made
a couple important stops at the
Galapagos Islands and here he observed
in a wildlife and made some observations
that would change the direction of
natural history you know friends since
he observed that finches which are a
type of bird finches all possess
different type of beaks that seemed to
help them survive in their particular
islands and you know after mulling over
his observations and meeting with other
experts and at the time and in 1859 he
eventually writes and publishes the book
the Origin of Species and in this book
he outlined you know the process of
natural selection which you know has
been refined over the years but the core
concept the main idea is that if
organisms possess an advantage they're
more likely to survive and reproduce
well let's go into that you know there's
really four factors that influenced
natural selection the first being that
nature tends to overpopulate meaning
more individuals are born than are going
to survive for instance we'll all of
these fish eggs live long enough to
reach adulthood age No many of them are
gonna die and be food for other aquatic
organisms you know we'll all of these
seeds survive long enough to grow into
mature plants and trees know many of
these seeds are gonna perish there'll be
food for other organisms you know we'll
all of these lion cubs live into their
adulthood years of life no probably not
there's a struggle to survive in nature
so nature tends to overpopulate in my
animation the rabbits are multiplying
they're reproducing now well all of
these rabbits survive in the wild no
probably not some of them are gonna fall
victim to predators
well our second fact
is that there are variations within
individuals of a population now this
population of rabbits has two major
distinguishable variations mostly brown
in color and mostly white in color well
the third factor is that some of these
variations allow a better chance for
survival
because we know that there is a struggle
to survive and what we mean by that is
there are our for instance predators
wolves that are on the hunt for rabbits
doesn't matter if they're brown it
doesn't matter if they're white the
wolves are hungry and they want to feed
so as the Wolves go out hunting you know
maybe they catch a brown rabbit even
though the brown ones are a little
harder to see the white ones stand out a
little more in this particular
environment so as the Wolves now
continue to hunt maybe a white rabbit is
captured and because white stands out a
little bit more more and more the white
rabbits tend to be captured so as time
goes by there's just fewer and fewer of
the white rabbits reproducing and
surviving and here we see another white
rabbit fall victim to the wolves so as
time passes the white rabbits are
becoming very very threatened now the in
brown in color does that guarantee
survival of course not as the white
rabbits become fewer and fewer in number
in population size the wolves are gonna
have to start hunting the brown ones so
even within the brown rabbits there's
variation because some of them might be
faster so it might be slower some might
be meteor some of them might be skinnier
and here we see a brown rabbit captured
and so finally the last of the white
rabbits has been hunted and the white
rabbits are no longer existing in this
ecosystem so that brings us to our
fourth factor is that over time those
were the advantages tend to make up most
of the population now did the white
rabbits turn into brown rabbits no of
course not the white rabbits were hunted
and eliminated by the wolves they no
longer exist in this particular
ecosystem so this is what we mean by
their survival of the fittest
in this environment the brown rabbits
were more fit they were more likely to
survive and reproduce
you know all these buffaloes have little
variations but are they all going to
survive you know that one's shorter that
one's fatter that one has bigger horns
that one's faster are they all gonna
survive no there's a struggle to survive
only the more fit ones are the ones
better likely to survive and reproduce
you know these fish even have little
tiny variations are they all gonna
survive you know that one might have a
little bit of a deformed fin and that
one might have poor eyesight that one
might have a faster metabolism that one
might have little brighter colors and so
are other I'm gonna survive of course
not no there is a struggle to survive
only the fish that are most fit will be
able to survive and reproduce
you know it's no different in plants or
all these trees gonna survive in the
wild they all have little variations you
know that one might have bigger thorns
that one might produce less chlorophyll
that one might have softer wood are they
all gonna survive no there's a struggle
to survive only the more fit plants and
trees are gonna be the ones that survive
and reproduce
you know I've mentioned a few times that
there's a struggle to survive and what I
mean by that is that there are limiting
factors there are factors that will slow
or stop population growth that nature
has to contend with
you know this graph right here shows
human population going back about 10,000
BC and for much of human history the
human population was very small and grew
at a very slow and steady pace but then
a couple hundred years ago we see that
the human population has skyrocketed and
now one thing that we know is that you
know this cannot continue forever
eventually there is going to be a lack
of resources that will prevent this from
continuing to grow at this rate but
we're gonna be talking about you know
what are some of these limiting factors
that affect not just human life but all
of their life on this planet
you know pause the video right now and
try to think of what are some examples
of limiting factors I'm going to go over
a couple in three-two-one
you know examples of limiting factors
might be a lack of resource such as
drinking water resources such as shelter
resources such as food
other examples of limiting factors could
be predators other examples could be
disease you know as populations tend to
get bigger disease tends to be more
common acts of nature can limit the
population from groans such as forest
fires and hurricanes you know these are
all examples that that limit the size of
population growth so the ability to
survive is aided by Fitness now when you
think of Fitness maybe this picture kind
of pops into your mind that's not the
type of fitness we're talking about
fitness means the ability to survive and
produce offspring
well this owl has high Fitness because
it blends into its snowy environment
it's better able to survive and
therefore reproduce
now this katydid is an insect that looks
an awful lot like a leaf
well this insect because it looks like a
leaf is able to blend into its
environment it's more likely to survive
and reproduce it has high Fitness as
well so if we come back to these brown
rabbits from earlier these rabbits have
shot have high Fitness in this
particular environment but if the
environment were to be changed you know
do the rabbits still have high fitness
in this snowy environment you can see
the answers no they're gonna be easily
hunted by the arctic wolves ironically
the war the white rabbits from earlier
would probably have much greater fitness
in this particular environment and they
would be the ones who would survive and
reproduce so looking at the human
population graph from earlier due to our
high intelligence and our ability to
solve problems humans have very high
Fitness this is why our population is
currently growing exponentially we've
been able to fight back disease we've
been able to build shelters we've been
able to produce more food and so
therefore we have high Fitness and were
able to survive in environments where in
the past we've not been able to
now why do all the fish in this school
look almost identical in appearance well
because this is the appearance that
produces high Fitness individual fish
that didn't look like this head low
Fitness and they most likely died out
long ago well why do cacti have sharp
thorns on them well because the thorns
prevent herbivores meeting them thorns
add to their fitness and so therefore
any cacti without these sharp thorns
would have died a long time ago
you know whitey drafts have a long neck
is it because they stretched to reach
tree tops no not at all
drafts have a long neck because it helps
them reach the food and this increases
their fitness drafts without long necks
would have starved drafts with
genetically longer necks had an
advantage they reproduced they made
babies with genetically longer necks and
there you go all the giraffes with
shorter necks were eliminated due to
natural selection so I want to start
mentioning a couple examples of natural
selection in action today and what
better way to start than by talking
about antibiotics you know antibiotics
are medicines that are designed to kill
bacterial infections now antibiotics can
kind of trace their origins back to dr.
Alexander Fleming who discovered the
very first antibiotic called penicillin
back in 1928 and in his lab dr. Fleming
was growing bacteria on petri dishes and
so it was very common here's a petri
dish and here's some bacteria smeared
all over the petri dish you know this is
a very common site for dr. Fleming and
when he was studying bacteria so I'm
returning from vacation dr. Fleming
noticed something strange when he
examined a dirty petri dish what he
noticed is that there was a big blob of
mold which is a type of fungus growing
on the petri dish now that in itself
wasn't strange
you know if you leave dirty dishes out
and dirty food out and old food it's
gonna attract mold and fungus that
wasn't the strange thing that he
observed what he noticed is that
surrounding the fungus there is a zone
where there was no bacteria growing so
he wonders could the fungus could the
mold be releasing some kind of chemical
that is killing the bacteria and then
could this chemical be actually
harvested and used to help fight
bacterial infections and eventually
after a lot of research a couple other
individuals couple other scientists were
able to isolate and purify and
mass-produced penicillin and penicillin
was mass-produced just in time for World
War two and it's a success was seen as a
miracle cure for many life-threatening
bacterial infections that had existed in
the past well how do antibiotics
actually kill bacteria here's some
bacterial cells and when you take an
antibiotic and that's what the black
dots are antibiotics when you take an
antibiotic they actually absorb into the
bacterial cell and then what they do is
they poke little holes in the cells of
the bacteria and eventually cause the
bacteria to burst
therefore ending the bacterial infection
and therefore you're on your road to
recovery but what we're seeing is that
there are some bacteria that possess
genes pieces of DNA that allow them to
resist the action of the antibiotic and
that's what the bacteria is labeled are
we're going to pretend they have the
resistant gene in them so when you take
the antibiotic the antibiotic enters all
the bacteria now only the bacteria
without the resistance have their cells
poked holes in and eventually they die
the ones that are resistant are
surviving and eventually going to
reproduce so as time passes the
resistant bacteria has survived and now
they're reproducing and I hope you see
where this is potentially a problem
because instead of your bacteria
infection going away and you getting
better you're now left with resistant
bacteria
thus antibiotics today are becoming less
effective and this is a real big problem
as we continue to struggle to find ways
to fight bacterial infections ok so
here's a little petri dish here and the
this petri dish has bacteria growing on
it the bacteria can be seen in the
background the hazy color in the
background of the pit of the petri dish
each white disc has been treated with a
different antibiotic and I've just
labeled the white disks a through eye
okay if you're in class I want you to
you know turn to your neighbor but right
now pause the video and try to answer
this question if you were infected with
this bacteria which antibiotics could
you use to treat the infection I'm going
to go over the answers in three two one
so the antibiotics that you could use
would be you can see the ones that are
left the three that disappeared you
would not want to use to treat this well
how do we know this when we notice
around for instance antibiotic a there's
a clear zone free of bacteria no
bacteria reside in that clar zone this
means the antibiotic is successfully
killing the bacteria and you can see a
clear zone around a D F G H and I well
you know we're actually seeing a similar
pattern through the use of pesticides in
this picture attract through spraying
pesticides on crops and pesticides are
used are chemicals that are used to kill
rodents in insects and caterpillars
turns out however some of these pests
are resistant they have genes in them
that will resist the pesticide and then
when they survive and reproduce with
other survivors who are also resistant
all their babies are resistant so over
time the pesticides become less and less
and less effective you know this is one
way we might want to consider supporting
more than
or use of organic farming which is
farming without the use of artificial
chemicals and pesticides you know I want
to take a moment to recognize Rachel
Carson the scientist who authored the
book Silent Spring one of the most
influential science books ever written
in her book she outlined the pesticide
DDT here is DDT being sprayed into a
lake and here's DDT being sprayed over a
forest now this was done to help fight
off mosquitoes and some of the diseases
that they might spread well it turns out
DDT is a carcinogen meaning it causes
cancer and she uncovered this in her
research that she was doing for the book
Silent Spring and eventually there the
research that she had performed led to
DDT eventually being banned in the
United States and so I just wanted to
quickly recognize Rachel Carson for the
influential work that she performed well
we're also seeing this pattern with the
use of fungicides you know here's a
person's foot with athlete's foot fungus
and ponga sides are medicines used to
kill fungal infections you know most
fungi die when you use a fungicide but
some are resistant and the resistant
ones will reproduce with others again
it's survival of the fittest we also see
this with antiviral medicines which are
used to end the virus infection most
viruses are eliminated but some are
resistant and those resistant will
multiply so it is survival of the
fittest so there you have it if you're
in my biology class you know pause the
video try to answer these questions I'm
happy to check your answers before
school or after school one day and you
know perhaps leave a comment in the box
below I'd love to hear what you thought
about this video thanks for watching